little short today because we have
another live stream coming up um
at uh about an hour and 45 minutes from
now
um
that
is celebrating the fact that it is well
depending on how you compute it
a third of a century
since mathematica
and wolfram language were first released
june 23rd 1988. actually that makes me
think i should explain this whole
question about why is there uncertainty
about what a third of a century actually
is
well that's partly because there's
uncertainty about
uh
what counts as
uh
whether whether it's a question of the
earth going around the sun whether it's
a question of the number of times the
earth has turned on its axis
it's a little bit complicated to compute
the number of uh
the number of days
how do you compute what corresponds to a
century what corresponds to uh
that uh appropriate if you slice up the
number of days or you slice up the
number of revolutions around the sun
whatever else i think it all starts with
the fact that you know how many days
other than a year well it's
for the earth to come back to the same
place that it was at before
relative to
the fixed stars i think it's usually the
first point of areas the constellation
of areas which is usually viewed as
being the way that you sort of decide
where the earth has got to around its
orbit because
and of course they're not really fixed
stars because
all the stars are moving they have
proper motions as they're called
stars are moving relative to each other
at certain speeds
and
over the course of for example
historical time the star charts that
were made in antiquity are no longer
quite accurate today
for several reasons i mean one because
of the stars moving around relative to
each other another because of the
procession of the equinoxes the fact
that the earth is
is the axis on which the earth is
rotating hasn't remained quite the same
but i think the um the question of how
many days are there in a year where you
say 365 but there aren't really there's
365 point i don't know what it is 2481
or something
and uh therein begins all the difficulty
of what uh what exact um
uh
the
and people have have come up with all
these different calendar systems you
know we have leap years to deal with if
we would have a precisely
leap year rule which says you add a
february 29th every four years
if the length of the year was exactly
365 an integer a whole number
plus one quarter then it will be enough
to just add one extra day every four
years but it isn't quite that and
instead it's a little bit less than a
quarter so that means that there's the
exception of what is it you don't add it
every 100 years but you do have it every
400 years and it's been rather an
elaborate scheme and that's the
those are the different uh systems of
the calendar that have been invented
over the course of time um the uh the
the one that we use is the so-called
gregorian calendar which was invented in
the 1500s by pope gregory because the
earlier calendar the julian calendar
kind of put in place by julius caesar
had kind of uh had has
why is it a bad thing if you have the
wrong number of days in your year well
the thing that tends to happen is that
then you'll end up with you know
christmas time for example ends up being
the middle of the in the middle of the
summer in the northern hemisphere for
example because the date you call
december 25th
has moved in terms of where that means
the earth is in its orbit
and
uh so and and what season it's in that
moves over the course of hundreds of
years and that had happened between the
time of julius caesar and the 1500s and
so it was
the a different scheme was was invented
at that time which is the one we used
today
there are of course many other
subtleties in computing what time it is
where um the one that i'll just mention
is some i haven't just learned about
this one recently um
time runs
effectively more quickly if you're in a
high gravitational field
than if you're not
and so
in particular
um
the
uh that means that and and so in our
models of physics you can actually kind
of understand why that's the case it's
in a sense a higher gravitational field
is associated with the presence of more
mass and more energy
and mass and energy are associated with
more activity
in this network that represents the
small scale structure of space
and so in a sense
more higher
higher gravity higher energy density
higher amount of activity in the
fundamental structure of space and so in
a sense time passes faster
and so that means that in places where
there is in a sense more gravity time
will pass faster
and that means that for example the
surface of the earth where we have the
gravity that we are used to the one
g of gravitational
attraction of us that holds us down to
the ground so to speak and makes things
drop to the ground and so on the uh
that's gravity which causes acceleration
at the rate of 9.81 roughly meters per
second per second
acceleration means that's the
you measure speed in like meters per
second or miles per hour or whatever
else
and this is the acceleration is the rate
at which that speed gets faster so it's
measured in meters per second per second
and so that 9.81 roughly meters per
second per second is roughly the
acceleration due to gravity on the
surface of the earth it varies a bit
over the over the different parts of the
earth and you know if you're on a near a
mountain if you have if the crust of the
earth is thicker in one place than
another it'll be somewhat variable but
if you compare that
with the center of the earth well there
isn't any gravity going in any
particular direction at the center of
the earth at least associated with the
earth because
the the force of gravity that's produced
by the mass of pieces of the earth is
pulling in all different directions at
the center of the earth because there's
pieces of earth in all those different
directions and so there's effectively no
gravity there so that means that for
example if you drilled a hole through
the earth
then you would
get to this point and you sort of were
to drop through that hole in the center
of the earth through the center of the
earth
then at the place where you're at the
actual center of the earth gravity will
be as much pulling you back the way you
came as pulling you forward the way
you're going
and so if you were dropping through that
through that hole you would just be sort
of coasting on the velocity that you
already got by the time you got to the
center of the earth and then by the time
you get to the other side of the earth
you're you've got uh the sort of the the
earth above you is pulling you up and
then you go back and you kind of
oscillate back and forth in this in this
tube and
going through the center of the earth
always having your maximum acceleration
maximum change of velocity
at the two ends and no change of
velocity no acceleration in the center
and so that means there's less gravity
in the center of the earth than there is
at the surface of the earth and you can
ask what does that mean
for the passage of time and the answer
is in the history of the earth
the effective passage of time is a few
days less time has passed at the center
of the earth than at the outside at the
than on the on the exterior of the earth
so it's a that's kind of another weird
effect small very small on the scale of
working out you know our one-third of a
century anniversary but nevertheless
kind of an interesting effect
all right let's see um
let's take some questions here that
people
had um
all right saved up from last time
and again i'm happy to try and address
any questions about science math
technology whatever there's one here
from you me
why do mathematical folk create models
if machine learning can create more
complex and better
models okay that's an interesting
question
all right so
what is a model of a thing
what does it mean to have a model of
something
it means you've somehow got some way
to
work out what will happen
or understand the thing
more simply than just by watching the
thing do what it's doing
so for example
it would be
if we say
we have i don't know
a
model
for
what's a good example how a person moves
through a crowd
or how a traffic jam happens
or how
a
or how heat uh moves through a a bar of
metal or something
all of these things
you could just trace
what happens to each person what happens
to each atom you could just trace every
detail of what's going on but sort of
the point well the the first thing to
say is is um
uh a model is is kind of trying to give
you a way to
explain or predict what's going to
happen
and
some models are more useful on the
explaining side than others so for
example a model that just says to find
out what will happen
in
the transmission of heat in a bar of
metal just follow every atom
that might work
but its ability to explain at a human
level what's going on is very low
because you'd be saying follow trillions
of atoms and work out what happens with
them and then the aggregate is going to
be this thing that we call the
transmission of heat or whatever a
diffusion of heat
um
so that that is low in terms of its
ability to kind of um
uh have a big picture explanation of
what's going on now of course the first
question is what what do you know the
underlying mechanism by which heat is
transmitted in this bar of metal and
for that just knowing whether these
atoms bouncing around and they do this
and that
that's a good underlying explanation but
it isn't an explanation that is a a sort
of top level human understandable so
this is how you can reason about what's
going on kind of explanation
well let's see let's let's zoom out for
a little bit um
at uh
um
talking about
the relationship between
essentially mathematical models machine
learning models and i'm going to add one
more which is kind of computational
models
so
some models
say i can understand the mechanism by
which this thing happens
and therefore i can compute what will go
on i can either do that by getting some
mathematical formula solving some
mathematical equation or i can do that
by having some program that i run that
reproduces how the system behaves so
that will be one kind of way to say what
will happen in a system
the other way you could say what will
happen in the system
is by just looking at examples of what
has happened in the system and trying to
just learn by example and just have
something where you've got a big
inventory a possible example you'd say
well if it looks like that it's going to
do this
next so let me give you the example of
weather forecasting
so back in the day
when i was a kid for example most
weather forecasting was done by looking
at the pattern of winds and pressure
high pressures areas and so on and just
saying meteorologists would just say hey
i've seen something a bit like that
before you know generally what happens
is the cold front moves this way and
that moves that way and so on it's
something where it's just you've got
this big inventory of i've seen
something like this before so i think i
know what's going to happen
what happened more recently was people
started having sort of first principles
computational models where it said we've
got this representation of the earth's
atmosphere in terms of uh packets of air
that are hot and cold and we've got
clouds they're difficult to model but so
be it we've got you know rain we've got
topography we've got winds all this kind
of thing and then we can just
mechanistically compute what's going to
happen so it's kind of the trade-off
between just match what happened before
without knowing how it works at all
and understand the mechanism and try and
explain what's going to happen based on
that mechanism
now
just knowing the mechanism doesn't
necessarily give you
a an explanatory story because you know
take the weather forecasting example you
might be running some big complicated
supercomputer computation and then it
says it's going to rain tomorrow but
that doesn't really give you
a a sort of an understanding an
explanation of why it's going to rain
tomorrow it just says you run the
computer calculation and it says it's
going to rain you know so be it um
it you know so that doesn't it's not
really a a human level explanation in
fact the other ex kind of explanation
that says when there's a pattern that
looks like this it tends to do this
might be a better human level
explanation
but anyway in modern times we have sort
of a way to automate that process of
just saying look at a bunch of examples
and say is it going to come out
according to the way these examples say
it's going to come out
and that way of doing things is machine
learning
and the idea there is you're just giving
you're giving all these examples and
you're saying okay when there's a new
example that comes in how would that uh
sort of how would that relate to the
examples you've already seen so for
example if you see an example that is in
this form and that form and the one you
see is sort of in some sense halfway in
between you say well the outcome is
probably going to be kind of halfway on
between the outcomes of these of these
examples that we previously saw
now the question of whether this is
going to work so so the the kind of the
thing that's happened over the last
little bit less than a decade
is dramatic improvement
in the ability to go from examples
and be able to say what's going to
happen in a new example
a version of that they're really two
very basic kinds of of ways that set up
classification and prediction so in
classification the basic idea is
you're showing lots of different
pictures of cats lots of different
pictures of dogs you're showing a new
picture and you're asked to classify is
this a picture of a cat or a dog
and so that's one type of task another
type of task is prediction that's more
what we're talking about here in these
science things perhaps
which is to say um if
we
see
oh i don't know
um
in the cats and dogs example
if we see a picture of a cat and it
looks like this
the weight of the cat will be
x
just based on the picture of the cat
let's say or the weight of the dog will
be this that would be an example of a
prediction problem and if we see kind of
two different
what we want is if we have the the the
saint burner that's really big and the
and the
uh poodle that's really small
and then we see some kind of dog that's
a mixture in between those and all we've
got is a picture
we our goal is to try and deduce try and
predict what will be the weight of that
intermediate dog
okay so how does that whole setup work
well
it works by
essentially having
well it works by using
a
a
a way of assuming that things are set up
that is very similar to the way of
assuming that things are set up that our
brains use
so let me see if i can explain roughly
how that works
um
so the idea is first of all every image
every piece of input that you give is
ground up until it's just a bunch of
numbers so in an image you might take
every pixel in the image and you might
say there's a red green blue value there
on in uh um
in sound you know you grind it up into
sound intensity as a function of time
and so on you're basically grinding
everything up until it's a bunch of
numbers
and that gives you sort of the beginning
of how you're starting to interpolate
between these numbers so what is
interpolation
let's say that you have
uh your
you have data let's say as a function of
time so you're saying you know it's you
know the values are 1 1 7
9 14 2 6 whatever
so we can those are all a bunch of
points
at different let's say equally spaced
times
and now we say okay
i want to know what happened in between
times 2 and 3 at time 2.5 for example
what happened
well the most obvious thing you can do
is just take all those points that you
might have plotted on a graph and just
draw a line that goes linearly between
each point so you've got this piecewise
linear approximation you just have a you
know you just put a line from one point
to the next and so on and then to work
out what will be the value between those
two points you're just looking at where
did the line reach at that particular
x-coordinate between those points that's
the most obvious uh kind of way of
interpolating between points but you can
be a little bit fancier than that you
can say i don't want those jagged edges
where the point comes up to the where
the line comes up to this point then
immediately comes down again let me
smooth it out a bit let me make a nice
smooth curve
and and you say well well that's nice um
you know i i can but but
you know then you have to ask the
question
how how elaborate should that curve be
if you've got all these data points and
they're they're in all these different
places maybe you want to just assume oh
there's a single smooth curve a single
let's say even even just a straight line
that goes through all the points but of
course it's probably not going to go
through precisely all the points
because some of the points will be a
little bit above a little bit below
maybe that happens because
those points were derived from some
experimental data and there were some
errors in the experimental data and so
the points were a little bit off where
they should have been and the real true
model is just that straight line single
straight line or the true model is that
single you know uh curve that just uh
has a sort of a simple
you know dome type shape or something
okay so
so the idea of interpolation is to fit
some kind of curve to your data and to
try and make it so that it well usually
in interpolation you try and go through
every point but to fit some model where
it's just you're fitting a curve you say
this curve is a representation of this
data and if you want to predict where
other data will be just follow just see
where that curve would be at that point
okay so all kinds of terrible things can
happen for example you can you can over
fit you can say i'm really insisting
that the that the curve correctly
reproduce every little detail of these
points that we laid down
even though some of those points might
be uh the result of experimental errors
and so on and you know even though it
might be that everything should be just
this nice straight line but there's this
one point that's out of uh out of where
it should be and oh we need to really
account for that one point so let's make
this this line really jig off to the to
to go through that point and maybe that
will be the right thing to do because
that point is very important or maybe
that will be the wrong thing to do
because that point was just a mistake
okay so in machine learning what one is
doing is essentially making those kinds
of um uh that that kind of sort of
interpolation through data at least
that's what one's doing one was doing
prediction in machine learning
when and that's and so what one can do
and one one's thinking about sort of use
machine learning from for science it's
like can one make that kind of just
given the examples you make that kind of
thing where you say anything that i'm
shown i'm going to get the answer based
on what i know happened in the in these
examples
well needless to say you don't get
something for nothing
in the end there has to be a model for
making the model so to speak so it isn't
the case that you can't decide just
purely in the abstract just from the
data oh this is the best model this is
the best
curve that fits the data or something
you have to have some overarching model
for models so to speak that says this
kind of curve is more likely to be right
than that kind of curve what's
implicitly happened in machine learning
is that the particular type of models
that are being used are ones that follow
somewhat the way that our brains work
the way that the sort of mathematical
functions the equivalent of mathematical
functions that you get from neurons
connecting to other neurons and causing
other neurons to fire and all this kind
of thing and so in a sense what is being
done in machine learning is that we're
following things that we humans say oh
that's reasonable
because that's kind of how our brains
would do it
so
uh the you know the thing that one can
then do is to say okay let's just by
example figure out what's going to
happen in the system in this uh system
in nature or this this thing we're
trying to compute scientifically that's
thing number one or thing number two is
let's try and understand the mechanism
by which the thing works and then try
and compute from the mechanism what it's
going to do
okay so
there are definitely trade-offs between
these different approaches there are
plenty of things where we don't know
anything about the mechanism really so
the only thing we can reasonably do is
to use machine learning let me give an
example let's say you're trying to
predict how humans are going to click on
different things on you know different
how they're going to respond to
different kinds of
news articles that you put on some news
feed well we don't really have a theory
of that we don't have a good
understanding mechanistic understanding
of how humans work at that level
so what we can best do is just say let's
look at a bunch of examples and then
let's use machine learning to basically
build that sort of model of of humans
based on just looking at examples and
again it's not a model this model there
is in the end machine learning is
picking they're an infinite number of
possible models you could pick machine
learning is picking one of those models
just as on the mechanism side when you
make try and figure out models
in science there's a certain tendency to
pick the simplest model consistent with
the data that's usually called occam's
principle or occam's razor after a chap
who lived in the uh twelve hundreds
maybe
william bockham i'm remembering
correctly who
who basically made this point you know
if you're going to make a theory for
what's going on
don't introduce all sorts of uh
unnecessary uh sort of ornateness to the
theory trying the most likely right
theory is the theory that's simplest
so that's that's sort of the mechanism
side but
if you ask what are the trade-offs
between a machine learning approach and
a
mechanism-based approach
the machine learning approach can work
within a certain domain but if something
sort of goes wrong if there's something
where
oh well in that case it would be going
at the supersonic speed and then
something completely different will
happen the machine learning method will
not tell you that machine learning
method will just say hey i've seen stuff
more or less like this before
and um uh you know so this is what is
going to happen but if something
unexpected happens it's not going to
know that because all it knows is what
it's kind of seen before whereas a
mechanism-based approach does have the
chance
if that that mechanism might lead to
something quite unexpected happening and
indeed that's what you see in a lot of
cases when you take simple programs and
you say what does this program what kind
of behavior does this program lead to
often the behavior you get is something
very complicated and very unexpected
based on the program itself
that's that's kind of not that
unexpected thing is not what you would
find from sort of the machine learning
side of things
now
you know in a sense there's a question
where has machine learning been
successful where is it not there's a
certain argument that it's been
successful in places where humans can
also be successful
finding you know that's cat that's a dog
things like that
there are other cases there are a few
other cases in science
notably recently protein folding
where machine learning seems to be
successful
i kind of suspect
that most of these successes when you
pull them back enough
are successes that are related to the
human way of processing
our image of the world so to speak our
view of the world
and for example i suspect
well i haven't thought about this
properly but it could very well be when
we say
uh oh it's so successful at doing
protein folding uh you know taking
figuring out these long molecules that
are the proteins that make biological
organisms like us up
um and figuring out how does that long
molecule some long molecules are very
very long and stringy some are very
globular they they kind of fold
themselves up into a glob
um and uh figuring out what shapes you
get based on what the sequence of units
are in the molecule um has been a hard
problem but it could be that in the end
when you say we've succeeded in doing
this folding problem what you're saying
is with respect to our description
of uh the description we care about
which is what
is know what molecule
that's a case in which we can
successfully use machine learning if we
were interested in other features
of the configuration that that exists or
something like that we might not be able
to use it for example if we were
interested in something like the um the
complete
evolution path and whether the whether
the molecule ever goes through some
particular configuration in getting to
that globular structure it might be less
useful i'm not sure
um but anyway the little bit of a
summary of um
these questions about
the relationship between modeling by
mechanism modeling by machine learning
in both cases there are significant
issues of saying why did it come out
that way and machine learning it's like
you open up the neural nets and it's
just got a bunch of these random
comparisons it's making random
computations it's doing it's very hard
to tell what it's doing similarly when
you study things by mechanism
it's often well you just run the program
it does all these complicated things and
in the end it comes out this way and
it's hard to have a an explanatory story
of what's going on although arguably it
can the in the mathematical approach
when when you end up getting a
mathematical formula kind of uh kind of
solution you can often do much better at
sort of humanizing the description of
the mechanism that's used there
let's see
um
uh
a question here which is
comparatively
simple
um he says famous last words that's
always those are always the ones that um
uh that i have the most trouble with
those are the questions that seem simple
from gist here
can you create gold from lead
by
having some lead next to a big pile of
plutonium
i think we've talked a bunch about
nuclear physics here but let me um uh
let me
talk about this a little bit
back in the 1400s 1500s things like that
people were obsessed with this idea of
doing alchemy
um alchemic you know alchemy wound up
later being things like chemistry but
alchemy
the the sort of the the big kind of uh
the holy grail of alchemy was turned let
to turn lead into gold
people knew that you could do chemical
reactions that would turn you know this
substance which is a white powder plus
this substance with the white powder
would turn into a green frothy liquid or
something and it seemed like you were
transforming mata from one one kind of
matter into another kind of matter so
the obvious question could you take a
base metal like lead that was really
easy to get and turn it into
a a precious thing like gold and that
would be like you could you could uh
make your own money so to speak uh you
know when there was when gold was sort
of the basis as it was in those times
for for monetary value you could just
take your pile of lead it's worth
nothing you put it in your machine and
out comes a string of beautiful gold
coins and then you're
you're rich and famous so to speak so
this was the goal of the alchemists for
hundreds of years was to find some way
to you know reduce it with you know
potassium permanganate and add heat it
to this in this way and and put some uh
you know
uh
put some silver around this and then
have that be happening at the time of
the full moon and so on nobody knew what
would be important
in determining what came out you know
maybe it mattered
that you were grinding it in certain
ways maybe it mattered that you had uh
some some strange thing that was the
kind of the um
uh
some strange plant that you would that
had some that grew in some odd place or
you know maybe it mattered that you had
you know the horn of a unicorn i think
those were actually narwhals or
something that were thought to be
unicorn horns but in any case maybe it
mattered that you had some some peace
people didn't know what mattered
but nobody managed to turn lead into
gold
so the question is why not and the
answer is because chemical reactions
what in in a when we have an atom it has
a nucleus made of protons and neutrons
it has electrons that are uh sort of far
away from the nucleus but still in that
tiny little atom
when you do chemical reactions what's
happening is you're rearranging the
electrons you're rearranging the way
that for example if you have two atomic
nuclei there can be electrons sort of
floating around between the nuclei that
bond those nuclei together they make a
covalent bond between those nuclei
things like that you can essentially
rearrange you know chemicals chemical
compounds have a bunch of atomic nuclei
and then they have electrons in some
complicated configuration which sort of
holds together the chemical compound so
when you have chemical reactions what's
always happening is the nuclei are going
to where they they're always kept
unchanged but instead the configuration
of the electrons is changed and that
means the positions of the nuclei can
change they can move around one some can
get bound to other ones for now and then
unbound and so on but the nuclei stay
the same
and what was realized by the mid-1800s i
guess is that although not in detail
because people didn't understand the
structure of nucleus until the early
1900s
the the idea that
that
well
you can change the electron structure
but you can't change the nuclear
structure and lead the difference
between lead and gold is a different
nucleus in particular the different
chemical elements are characterized by
the fact that they have different number
of protons in the nucleus of their atoms
so hydrogen 1 helium-2
hydrogen helium
three beryllium four et cetera et cetera
et cetera down to lead which is
what is lead um
gold i think is 79 protons and
lead is like
989
90 protons something like that
so basically you have two different
kinds of nuclei for lead and gold
okay
how can you change one nucleus into the
other well the answer is you have to
kick it really hard and then you can
eject some protons from the lead nucleus
and eventually if you eject just the
right number of protons you'll wind up
with a gold nucleus it's pretty hard to
achieve that
because most of the time if you kick the
nucleus hard enough by having some high
energy particle like maybe a neutron
that was
came out of a nuclear reactor that's
just tooling along and it bashes into
the nucleus and kapow the nucleus falls
apart
the um it's uh that doesn't typically
end you up with oh and i got exactly the
right number of protons to wind up with
gold
but
by by sort of careful arrangement you
could perhaps i don't know how easy it
is to do this you could perhaps i mean
nuclei tend to be bound tightly together
by nuclear forces and if you like kick
them hard enough that pieces fall off
i think it tends to be the case that the
nucleus will sort of will typically
shatter rather than the nucleus just
having a little piece that falls off
here
um so i think it's tough to do that
and uh the the question asked had to do
with plutonium plutonium is an element
which is naturally radioactive in the
sense that
its nuclei
its nuclei pieces fall off the nucleus
and i'm trying to remember what
plutonium is an alpha emitter i'm not
sure but maybe has spontaneous
proficient i'm not sure um but the
they're different ways in which the
nucleus either bits can fall off the
nucleus spontaneously or the nucleus can
just sort of fall apart spontaneously
into into let's say two big pieces and
that's what's happening in plutonium uh
there that you there's no stable
plutonium the nucleus won't hang
together
for for
for an infinite time and so pieces fall
off those pieces can go hit other nuclei
like they could hit lead nuclei and do
something to those lead nuclei i think
it's tough to arrange it to wind up just
turning into gold as opposed to turning
into gold together with mercury together
with this together with that all these
different um all these different
elements um so in principle but in
practice no and you know it's almost i i
suspect if you do that with nuclear
physics it's almost kind of like panning
for gold in the sense that you'll just
get a whole bunch of different nuclei
out then you have to go separate the
nuclei and say hey is one of those a
gold nuclei nucleus great and in doing
all of that stuff you will spend a lot
more than it costs to mine another ounce
of gold out of the ground
um
okay there's a question here
uh
from
gekko gekko
how proportional is public opinion of a
person to the actual achievement of that
person generally
boy well we're not we're a little bit uh
out of the science and technology zone
here it's interesting to look at that
question historically
there are people who are very famous in
their time and unknown some time later
there were people who were almost
unknown in their time and became very
famous later
and i think
there are
different kinds of things that happen
so for example
at any given time there are things where
sort of everybody knows this is
important
and
well it's important at the time
but then later on in history it's like
who cares
like for example there was a time when
it was really important to try and make
better mechanical calculators
and people made i don't think anybody
got terribly famous doing this but
people made you know the better and
better mechanical calculators through up
through the 1960s and so on and then
electronic calculators were invented and
like nobody cared about those
achievements they're magnificent but
nobody cares
and
so
that was a thing where where sort of the
tide of history caused what might have
been an important achievement in its
time to look unimportant later because
the context of what people were thinking
about had changed
so there are cases where
i mean that there are different things
that determine sort of the visibility of
people at a given time
i mean another thing is in science for
example
there's sort of
a certain there's people who will go off
and figure out a bunch of great science
there are people who will do that and
not be able to explain it to anybody
and
sometimes
you can see from the effects from the
results oh this person computed this
number and somebody did an experiment
and they measured that number and it
came out right there must be something
wonderful there even though the person
is not very good at explaining what they
did and nobody can really understand
what was going on inside
um
and so that's a case where sort of
there's there's but but somebody had to
care about that number it's the same in
mathematics
if somebody there are these famous
problems fermat's last theorem the
riemann hypothesis
uh things like this go back's conjecture
these are in a sense
somewhat random problems out of the set
of all possible problems in mathematics
but if somebody solves the go back
conjecture for example
that will be a person very famous in
mathematics
um
uh probably because that's something
which because of sort of the history of
people talking about it etc etc etc it
seemed like an important thing now it
might turn out
that
the
uh well the four color conjecture the
four color theorem whether you can take
a map of the world for example
and use only four colors to color the
countries with the constraint that no
countries that are adjacent will ever be
the same color that was kind of a a big
deal you know is somebody going to prove
it is it not going to be proved in the
end it was proved by rather
as many mathematicians thought a rather
brute force mundane computer-based sort
of uninteresting proof and so you don't
hear so much about that anymore because
it was kind of like well yeah it kind of
got worked out but it got worked out in
in a not so mathematically interesting
way
so anyway there's this there's a sort of
question is the thing that's being done
famous in its time
does it become famous a lot later does
it is it does it become the case i mean
for example
uh einstein's general theory of
relativity very famous today
when it was first invented it was famous
but it wasn't nearly as famous as it is
today actually better example uh the
turing machine alan turing's uh
invention of sort of a mechanical
concept for how computers might work
uh really not that famous at the time
1936
became much more famous later when
people really started understanding the
context of computing and the fact that
what turing had discovered was more
universal and people had thought and so
on and so that sort of the fame of that
gradually increased
i mean
i think
there is these different dimensions is
the thing something where people know to
care at that moment in history that's
one parameter another parameter is is
the thing being explained in a way that
people can understand there can be some
brilliant theory but it's explained
so in such uh difficult to understand
terms that you even sometimes wonder did
the person who invented it really
understand it or did they just sort of
throw things together and it sort of
happened to work and the next person
down the line might have thrown things
together and it might have sounded the
same but it didn't happen to work
so that's that's another piece um
another thing that can happen is in
cases where things are not very clear
it can be the case that somebody has
sort of put pieces together
and at the time it's like nobody that
people say oh well i don't know what
that means then later on for other
reasons things become very clear and
then you go back and you say by golly 50
years ago 100 years ago 200 years ago
that person they really nailed it they
really got it now that we can see how it
all works out we can see that what that
person was talking about at that time
really had got the essential point
that's a tricky one that's a tricky one
to know what to really conclude from
that whether in fact what one is seeing
is something where the person didn't
really understand what does it mean to
understand it if you went back and
interviewed that person
in modern terminology the person would
have no idea what you're talking about
because those terms that whole context
hadn't been invented in that time so if
it was do they understand in terms of
your interview what they were talking
about the answer would be no and you
might say well then the person didn't
figure anything out but that wouldn't be
fair either that wouldn't be right
either it would be because there might
be something that was figured out it
might even be a thing which in the
person's own mind was completely clear
just not communicated very well to
anybody else
okay so the other side of the effect
is there are people at any given time in
history who are really good at
describing science
and um the
uh
and at explaining things
but that is an independent skill well
maybe not such an independent skill
it is not a skill that is entirely
correlated with the ability to develop
new science there are people who are
very good at explaining science
and who have never particularly done
research
and discovered new science maybe they've
done some research but they aren't sort
of major producers in terms of new
science but they're quite good at
explaining what
already exists and there are people who
are good at doing new science who are
terrible at explaining what exists or
even explaining what they themselves
have done
i tend to favor the idea i have to say
because i've known a lot of people
who've discovered a lot of a lot of
interesting things in science and so on
i would say that the vast majority of
people maybe it's somewhat selected by
people that i choose to interact with
the vast majority of people who've done
important things in science are actually
not bad at explaining what's going on
they may have
uh they may have better or worse you
know english writing skills they may
have the ability only to write a very
technical paper that can be understood
only by a narrow set of people but in
the end if you talk to them their
understanding of what's going on is
usually quite clear um it's not
you know there there are cases where
there are people where
i can think of some mathematicians for
example where
uh i think one has to know a lot to be
able to sort of untangle what is this
person really talking about
um but i think the um so so you know
what can happen is that you can have a
situation where people say
you know
uh
oh
um it's
only the messenger is important so to
speak it's kind of like people who say
uh you know
i i found this thing in a through a in a
search engine you know as if the search
engine is the thing responsible for the
content it's not it's responsible for
helping you find the content but the
content
is coming from somewhere else it's some
random website that got put up by by
somebody um so it would be similarly in
kind of
understanding science there's the well i
learnt about that
from
messenger x so to speak from this person
who explained it that's an important
skill in its own right but that isn't
necessarily the originating um
you know that typically won't be it's a
it's a somewhat rarer case where the
explanation goes hand in hand with the
actual uh doing of the frontline science
i mean i i myself put a lot of effort
into explaining things
as you know doing sort of frontline
science and explaining that frontline
science i have to say in my own
experience that is a slightly
self-defeating activity and the reason
is that in sort of the professional
doing of science people are used to the
idea that it isn't the same people that
explain stuff well and do the frontline
stuff and so if the frontline stuff is
explained really well people are like
can this really be the frontline stuff
because usually it's only explained
after the fact actually they're wrong in
that belief if you go back and look at
the original papers of many different
things it is it is common not always the
case maybe a third of the time the
original paper is beautifully clear and
the things that came later were much
less clear sometimes the original paper
is not so clear and the typical reasons
for that are either
the the kind of the notation that the
person is using is is very funky or the
original motivation that caused the
paper to be written
is one that is hard for us to understand
now
or
or something about kind of the notation
that's used i mean you know if you take
alan turing's paper on the on the turing
machine you know um the the um
uh the title the paper is on computable
numbers
and
something like a solution to the end
science problem
okay now is that really the paper that
you expect introduces the idea
well one of the one of the versions of
of um
of this is how computers are going to
work no it's a it's a it's a paper much
more obscurely titled now it's actually
a paper where the introduction and the
basic structure of the paper is very
nice and clear
the notation that's used is is quite
impenetrable it's it's full of these
bizarre gothic letters and it's just
it's complicated it was the first
computer program in some sense and one
didn't know how to write nice clean
structured programs in those days and it
wasn't a nice clean structure program
actually was also full of bugs but um uh
you know it's it's a um and by the way
alan turing is a good example of
somebody
who yeah that's an interesting story as
well the question is what is the
relationship between the personal story
of a scientist let's say
and
their
degree of of how seriously one takes
them or how seriously people take them
and that that's a very messy story it's
a very messy story because there are
scientists where
looking back in history perhaps even at
the time you say oh that person was a
terrible schmuck for this or that reason
you know
good science gets done by schmucky
people good science gets done by very
unschmucky people you know bad science
gets done by very unschmucky people it's
a it's a whole mixture and so again
that's not a um and sometimes there are
people who were
famous in their time
because oh that person they're looking
back in earlier times in history you
know that person was a famous diplomat
oh they were also a mathematician on the
side
and you know probably in that time they
were mostly known
as
a diplomat and it's only after the fact
that they get known as a mathematician
so i think
in um
uh and
in
in uh you know it is it's a funny thing
because because
you know you also can ask the question
uh
no one to whom so to speak
um
the uh
yes i think the question was public
opinion of a person
so that's a complicated story as well
because the public
in quotes
typically perhaps unfortunately doesn't
really know that much about what's sort
of happening at the front lines of
science i in my own efforts i've tried
to expose what we're doing at the sort
of front lines of science
as publicly as possible because i think
it's kind of interesting and i think
it's a worthwhile thing to do
um but uh
normally most frontline science gets
done sort of behind closed lab doors or
behind closed university doors or
whatever and it's not it's not
immediately visible it only becomes
visible to the public
uh you know after there's either you
know the news report of the cool thing
that got discovered or more likely the
kind of the description of things that
gets written by a quotes popularizer of
science typically not the same people
not always not the same but typically
not the same people as the people who
made the frontline discovery
so
um
it's uh uh it's it's a it's a sort of
complicated mixture of um of those
things
well i think uh we should
um
go
i do just one more one more question
here and then we should wrap up because
um
uh
i
want to
get ready for our one third of a century
mathematical celebration
okay there's a question here from
uh
rbs on how would one build a ufo what
technology would be needed mathematical
achievements and so on
i'm going to argue
that
that question is is philosophically
wrong
if we built it it is not an unidentified
flying object
presumably it is an identified flying
object because we built it and we know
what it is by the way i think um the the
modern term for uh ufos that identified
flying objects
um
seem to be i think they peaked in
interest around in the 1950s
where people were reporting ufos all the
time of you know there's this strange
thing and probably there were some
strange things because probably a bunch
of you know air force tests of all kinds
of strange vehicles and maybe there were
spy planes from other countries being
flying over and all kinds of funky stuff
going on
you know in the sky so to speak um
the uh the sort of modern term the
modern
uh i don't know
i wouldn't say scientifically correct i
wouldn't say politically correct either
but the modern uh more delicate term is
uaps unidentified aerial phenomena
actually there's a project um
being which i suppose i'm somehow some
kind of advisor to um that um
because i like these kinds of things
that's trying to uh it's
a galileo project
just started up a few months ago that's
trying to
detect unidentified aerial phenomena
and
the the basic idea is
you just put
cameras that are watching the sky
everywhere and you see if they're funky
things that show up there and it turns
out
that
if you are interested in things that are
pretty high up like 30 000 feet or
something you don't need that many
cameras to cover let's say the us you
need maybe i don't know 20 25 or
something things you put them somewhere
and they're looking up at this kind of
cone of sky
and uh just like from a plane at 35 000
feet you can see 240 miles
assuming that there isn't that that it's
a clear day
that's the distance it is to the horizon
based on the the height you are above
the above the curved earth so to speak
and so similarly uh if you have this
camera that's looking up at a cone of
sky
it can see a long way around it so long
as you're asking how to see only things
that are quite high up and so you don't
need that many of those uh sort of
cameras you put them on trucks or
something and move them to different
places around around let's say around
the us and then you can kind of pretty
much map out is there anything funky
going on in the in the sky so to speak
and i have to say i'm i'm
i mean i assume one will detect
obviously won't see all the planes go by
but one presumably knows where all the
planes are and um the um and
occasionally one will see a meteorite or
something like this and maybe we'll see
some strange phenomena my uh
my guess is that it'll be meteorological
phenomena that one sees that are
unexpected more so than uh you know the
strange interstellar spacecraft type
thing
now if the question is how would you
make an interstellar spacecraft that's a
that's an entirely different question
and that's a question we really don't
know the answer to yet i mean there are
efforts to make really tiny interstellar
spacecraft i think i even have a little
little sample of one of those things
tiny little tiny little sort of single
chip thing
where you imagine you have a giant kind
of uh solar sail type thing where you
have something pushed by light pressure
that um you can kind of have a laser
that shines on the thing and sort of
keeps pushing it and pushing it away um
until it goes sort of off to the the
different um star system takes a really
long time even you know going at a
decent speed it takes by decent speed i
mean a significant fraction of the speed
of light it takes a while to get four
light years to the nearest other star
and i think the um people don't know by
the time you're going
at you know 99 of the speed of light or
something like this
uh you know if you run into anything at
that speed
it's bad news and it's complicated
dynamics of and you know in interstellar
space there is roughly only one hydrogen
atom per cubic meter
but
uh i don't really know the extent to
which
kind of you know it's it's like um if
you're going fast enough you're still
going to see those impacts and i don't
really know what effect that has and how
difficult that is to deal with when it
comes to you know taking
uh
us humans off to um
other
uh
you know other solar systems and so on
that's a pretty tall order and um i you
know i kind of wonder you know there
have been a bunch of science fiction
movies um there's one quite recently
about that oh i don't know what it was
about but um well i can't remember what
it was called but but um about uh you
know the the perils of sort of multiple
generations existing on some spacecraft
uh you know this is our world type thing
for the next however many generations
until we can reach a nearby star um it'd
be interesting to to speculate on
uh
you know how that would work out um i
think uh you know it seems pretty
challenging it doesn't seem like the
form factor of uh human biological
organisms is particularly well suited to
interstellar travel and i i kind of
think that it's you know it's it's more
the it's it's more for our computers
than for us i would say and at a time
when you know we might have sort of a
a human-like consciousness that we can
say it's uploaded into this computer
it's like those are the things to go off
and uh explore the rest of the galaxy i
think it all becomes very very
virtualized very quickly and very much
related to questions about sort of what
do we really mean by intelligence and so
on and we've got this this lump of of of
stuff that is running all these
computations and and it's off to the
nearest star and it's concluding this
and that and it becomes a sort of very
philosophically complicated issue so i
think the your average um
the only thing to say about your average
um ufo of the past was people were like
well i know what a plane is i know what
a kite is maybe i know what a helicopter
is but something that's a flying saucer
which was a very common uh sort of shape
of these things maybe they're lenticular
clouds or something but but um very
common shape from the 1950s the flying
saucer type thing
it's like what will let you have a
saucer-like object that can just fly and
i have to say as is so often the case
you know a modern drone
with uh you know a multi-rotor drone
could look an awful lot i'm sure you
could make it i bet somebody's done this
um to make a flying saucer-like thing
feels like a good kickstarter kind of
kind of campaign to you know the flying
saucer drone that it looks like a
classic 1950s flying saucer but actually
it's flying because it has 10 rotors
embedded in it that are uh that are
spinning around and um in the past that
wouldn't have been possible to make the
control system to have a sort of 10
rotor device fly stably but but now it
is
all right we should wrap up here and um
uh thanks for those interesting
questions
and for those who are interested we have
another live stream coming up
uh celebrating our one-third of a
century of
mathematica and more from language
coming up soon
so thanks and